ناجونا من الزلزال ينبشون الانقاض بحثا عن
الذهب
اتقي الله في ابنتي جمله تشعل سوشيال
ميديا في مصر
رجل يدفع ربع مليون دولار كاجرا لزوجته عن
عملها بالبيت
هذا الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد مرور نحو شهر على وقوع الزلزال المدمر
بدا ناجون منه في تركيا بالبحث عن
مدخراتهم بين انقاذ منازلهم تقارير كشفت
ان غالبيه الناجين سواء في تركيا او سوريا
فقدوا كل شيء تقريبا من مقتنياتهم الثمينه
خصوصا المجوهرات الذهبيه لافته الى اقتناء
المعدن النفيس في المنزل يعد افضل من
ايداع النقود في البنوك بالنسبه للكثيرين
في الشرق الاوسط وفي تركيا تحديدا واوضحت
التقارير ان الاتراك يلجاون لاقتراع الذهب
ايضا لتحوط من التضخم المتزايد والانخفاض
الحاد في قيمه الليره التركيه في السنوات
الماضيه
اتقي الله في ابنتي جمله اشعلت ما وقع
التواصل في مصر حيث تفاجا عريس في محافظه
الاسكندريه اثناء عقد قرانها على عروسه
بهذه الجمله مكتوبه في قائمه المنقولات
الزوجيه العريس قال للعربيانات ان والد
عروسه طلب منه الامضاء على القائمه التي
كتب فيها فقط من يؤتمن على العرض لا يسال
عن المال اتق الله في كلمتنا
وفيما اعتبر البعض ان هذا الامر يعد
انتقاصا من حق العروس ولا يحق للاب ان
يفعل ذلك اخرون اعتبروه نوعا من التيسير
وظن الخير
من جديد عاد الملياردير الامريكي ايلون
ماسك لاثاره الجدل هذه المره بسبب طرده
موظفا من ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه في تويتر
على الملا بعد نقاش دار بينهما وفي سلسله
من التغريدات شكك ماسك في اعاقه الموظف
الذي بدا النقاش بسؤال حول ما اذا ما زال
موظفا ام لا في تويتر بعد 9 ايام من تجميد
حساباته ليرد بتغريره اخرى على ماسك بعد
ذلك قائلا له انه تلقى بريدا الكترونيا
يؤكد اقالته فيما اعتذر مالك منصه تغريدات
لاحقا بعدما واجه موجه واسعه من
الانتقادات
في خبرا اثار ضجه واسعه في مواقع التواصل
امرت محكمه اسبانيه رجل اعمال بدفع 218
الف دولار لزوجته كاجر عن عملها مده 25
عاما بالبيت في تسويه طلاق نهائيا وسائل
اعلام افادت بان القاضيه حسبت المبلغ على
اساس الحد الادنى لاجر مهنيا شهريا طوال
خمسه وعشرين عاما من الزواج مشيره الى ان
على الزوج ايضا ان يدفع لطليقته البالغه
48 عاما معاشا تقاعديا قدره 500 دولار كل
شهر ومبلغا اخر لابنتيه فيما انقسم جمهور
السوشيال ميديا ما بين مؤيد ومعارض لهذا
الحكم
وفي خبرنا الاخير اعلن تطبيق تيك توك
الصيني الشهير انه سيسمح لبعض صناع
المحتوى بانتاج مقاطع اطول فاتحا بذلك
بابا جديدا لمستخدمه لكسب المال الخدمه
الجديده التي تحمل اسم سيريز ستتيح لصناع
محتوى المؤهلين وضع مجموعات تصل الى 80
مقطعا مصورا طويلا وتصل مده كل منها الى
20 دقيقه علما ان اطول مده يسمح بها تيك
توك حاليا للمقاطع المصوره هي عشر دقائق
لما يدخل التطبيق الصيني بهذه الخدمه غمار
المنافسه مع عملاق جديده في عالم السوشيال
ميديا وهو يوتيوب